now the first time Molly was here his
kids were unfollowing him on social
media because you embarrassed them and
now we have found out that your son is
now asking you to embarrass him by
raiding his looks on social so we just
want to we just want to show this to
everybody
all right so here's the next fit yes all
right
um I don't like the Scooby-Doo shirt
um I like the Shaggy pants I don't know
what sneakers those are they're the New
Balances the two white guys strangers
all right yeah four but look at the bag
oh two sorry oh my God
my first thing about it if you watch it
again it looks like your son is holding
your head like you have to be a part of
it it looks like his hand is behind your
head like forcing you to be part of it
that's just how he's always been with me
it's like it's so it's like a form of
affection it just kind of grabs my head
he's like dead dead and he navigates my
neck where he wants it and he used to do
that when he's a kid when he was like
three he would dead dead and moved my
head everywhere and now he's 20 and he's
still like Dad Dad he just wants you to
focus yeah that's what it is
like I'm talking to you but I want to
talk to everyone yeah every last single
one of them okay and then talk to people
back there I just wanna I like you know
I see everything like a like a flying so
he just tries to get me to focus and
it's funny because
he unfollowed me on social media now you
want to be a part me to be a part of
your social media oh how the time to
turn
I am ADHD so this interview should go
well oh perfect we're both gonna be like
squirrel
um so we found another fashionable guy
for you to rate so here we just wanted
you to take a what do you think about
this look right here that's pretty good
pretty good it's from like 98 Maybe
maybe I was ahead of my time if you look
at it you know now everybody want to
wear the baggy stuff again I love that
the baggies come back around I do love
that I'll get out of that's about a you
know I'll give it about I had no chest
so I
if I had a chest it'd be a 10 so that's
about an eight that's nice yeah I grew a
chest last year so you grew
yeah I'm late with my puberty things
okay so we have one more so here we go
we're gonna look at this one what do you
rate this one
my my favorite part in my mind there's
no scar anything wrong you just are
wearing the Band-Aid I was like 14 in
that picture I'm pretty sure it was a
pimple Beyond
but I don't I don't I'll be honest I
don't really like the Jack the the vest
it looks heavy and hot look like it make
my underarms think so I'm I know but at
the time this was rocking I like the
jabot pants yeah this once again I
didn't have a chest so I just I like
your eyes too look at your eyes you're
serious about it the eyebrows yeah
you're serious about it says Mark
you ain't ready for this I did an outfit
of four I get an eyebrow with 13.
[Music]
thank you
yeah
guys I'm going
[Music]